to some of those travelers who are
heading into town despite those high gas
prices and all the expected travel
delays our mary jane belly has spoke
with those coming into town mary jane
summer is in full swing and many people
are hitting the road ahead of the fourth
of july weekend
aaa estimates 48 million people will
travel 50 miles or more from home over
the holiday weekend gas in the u.s is
about two dollars more per gallon than
it was this time last year
with an estimated 42 million americans
traveling by car setting a new record
for road trips david colen from
california is making a stop in las vegas
after a 23 day road trip we haven't paid
more than five dollars for a gallon of
gas until
yesterday just outside of colorado and
utah those were like in the low fives
but everything else was you know mid
four dollars four dollars and fifty
cents four dollars and eighty nine cents
driving definitely gave us the
flexibility to change our plans
originally we were going to yellowstone
it closed
total we just pivoted and we just said
okay well we're going to go to chicago
illinois instead visitors jesus crews
and ruth gonzales say to prepare for
traffic delays and leave early if you
can you know what let's just go for it
it's almost the same by
taking the plane so might as well just
take a road trip and it's our first time
here so we decided to come and check out
everything mary jane bellassa live local